A temple in India holds riches and curses.
Then are we on the cusp of a modern-day zombie outbreak?
Seriously. Seriously.
You guys are like nothing serious, but no, no, it's an interesting one.
And then we find a man who can eat anything. Yes?
Anything. Today on Dead Rabbit Radio.
I'm a big doll. Actually, I'm a hot big doll.
Hey everyone, welcome back to another episode of Dead Rabbit Radio.
I'm your host Jason Carpenter. I'm having a great day.
I hope you're having a great day too. This is take four.
I've spent the past hour here doing different takes, driving me nuts.
Money's are actually really hard to do because I've been out of practice for a while and I'm like, "Urrrgh!"
But so goes the world of podcasting.
There is a guy on YouTube. Not a YouTuber as far as I know, but they're one of my listeners on YouTube.
I love you to death, dude.
You suggested that I do a story and I thought, "Oh yeah, that would be an interesting one because I had a vague knowledge of it."
But Pondroll, Pondroll, I know I've seen you pop up on a couple different videos.
I've seen you commenting on a few of my podcast videos on YouTube.
And I know you listen to the show.
So when you suggested this story, you knew the torment you were about to unleash on my audience.
Because I have a hard time pronouncing cities in America.
And Pondroll suggested a story that takes place in India.
Now, the story is...
The Padman Abbaswamy Temple.
I'm not even going to try that one again. The Temple.
And it is this side, Pondroll, really. I love you and I'm... Thanks so much for listening. Thanks so much for the suggestion.
But there's this temple in India that...
There's this temple in this India that there was always this legend that it was full of treasure.
This is going to be a fairly short story.
But there was always this rumor that there was this treasure in this temple.
And back in... What was it?
20... So, but back in 2011, the government said, "You know what? Let's go through and find out actually what's in this temple.
We should catalog it." Because it's been there since like 3 A.D.
And they're like, "Hey, finally getting around to it, right? Let's do this."
While they were snooping around the temple, they found six hidden doors that they never knew was there.
And we'll get into that in a second, because that's an interesting thing.
You find these six hidden doors and they basically label them A through F.
Now, I don't think they used the English letters, but it was basically just like, this is door A, this is door B, so it's C, so on.
But in Indian letters.
And so, they start opening the doors and they find amazing riches.
Gold, ancient gold coins, diamonds, gems, diamond necklaces encased in gold.
With gems, I don't know, just these amazing artifacts.
And they're like, "Oh my God, we're rich!"
I mean, we're the government, so we're rich anyways, but we have this untold, unheard of fortune just laying in this temple.
They're opening the doors and they're like, "Doo-lulululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululululul
And what it says is that door B has a legend behind it.
Now, back in the 1930s, that region was super, super poor and they were actually going there having like a starvation issue.
Which I mean, I guess it's just starvation, that's the issue.
They didn't have enough food.
Now, this is what I thought was weird, because in 2011 they said, "Let's go see what's in this temple."
But in the 1930s, they go, "Hey, we're pretty sure there's a bunch of winking gold coins in that temple. Let's go in there."
And for whatever reason, the first door they tried to open was door B, and...
Sorry, that didn't happen in 1930.
That happened a hundred years ago.
So in 1900, the region was... something else happened in 1930.
So in about 1900, the region's super poor and they're starving and everything like that.
They go to open door B, and they hear a curious sound on the other side of door B.
A sound you shouldn't hear on the other side of any door in existence.
That's the sound of the ocean.
And they're like, "Eh, let's not open this. Let's not go here."
And they thought this door must lead to the Arabian Ocean, which actually I figured would be closer to Saudi Arabia,
but apparently it's also close to India.
They have big coastlines, but anyway, so they didn't.
And then there's just a bunch of people starved.
I don't know why they didn't try the other doors.
Maybe they didn't know the other doors were there, because they were so well hidden.
In the 1930s, some burglars were like, "Hey, dude, sometimes when I'm walking by that temple, I hear the sound of coins winking at me."
So they try to open door B, and a bunch of snakes jump out of the door and chase them off.
Noxious snakes is the term.
So a smelly snake.
Or unless the word means something else that I don't know of.
To this day, that door has never been opened.
Door B has never been opened.
And the legend is that only a cleric or a high level saint can open it.
So break out your Final Fantasy VII saves and see if you have...
I don't know if there are saints in that.
But anyways, break out your role-playing game.
Whatever role-playing game you do, level up your saint, try to open this door.
Because they believe that it is sealed by magic.
And unless the seal is broken, even though the door they believe can be opened with modern technology,
i.e. dynamite, they think that opening the door without removing the magic will cause great catastrophe to the region.
Like a giant new Arabian ocean emptying into the middle of India.
I think it's interesting because the door has the images of snakes on it.
And it had images of something else I couldn't pronounce.
Again, thanks, Pongraal.
And those images are associated in Indian mythology or Indian culture as being warning signs.
I mentioned once before that there was a group of people who were trying to design a warning logo
that could be interpreted 10 million years in the future.
Because we want to bury all this nuclear waste in Nevada.
But they don't want anyone stumbling across the, you know, long after we're gone and opening the doors
and irradiating the entire western half of the United States.
So they go, "What type of image can we come up with that millions of years from now
people will not interpret as anything other than dangerous?"
A skull, a lot of times that represents religious.
So if archaeologists in the future stumbled across a giant skull in the middle of a desert on a door,
it may not necessarily equate that with death.
For the most part, it hasn't been equated with death.
For a long time in human history, skulls meant rebirth or religion.
But they're saying that this is a warning, do not open this door.
I think that's really interesting because who knows what's behind it.
Is it more gold, diamonds, the size of an infant?
Is it something, is it some magical portal to somewhere else?
Is it a super weapon that was hidden there?
Or is it just an empty room? We don't know.
And it's funny because the Indian government is in no hurry to figure it out.
So that is the story of the temple I can't pronounce.
Indiana Jones and the temple I can't pronounce.
You know what's so funny is intriguing is the story is it delves a lot into Indian mythology
and I just can't pronounce the words.
And I'm not going to put you through that.
So we're leaving India.
We'll probably be back to India at some point because they do have a lot of cool mythology.
It's the language barrier. I just can't pronounce that stuff.
And I don't like to give foreign places nicknames like "Padaha Mata Ta Ta Castle".
We'll just call it "Patti". I don't like to do that.
But anyways, so we're off.
Now, we're going from India and the legends involving that to Africa, modern day Africa.
Now we're in the Congo. Now this is an interesting story because this just popped up in the news.
They're having an Ebola outbreak again. It's not just any Ebola outbreak.
This is the second biggest Ebola outbreak in history.
Now, they've had them and it's been fairly restricted to villages.
And they go, "Okay, that's not like a good thing."
And I'm like, "Yay, just villages."
But it could have been a lot, lot worse.
And the problem is, is that we might be there now.
Because they have this city. It's called Butembo in the Congo.
And it has a population, it's a city.
It has a population of over a million people.
And Ebola has not hit a major city yet.
And we're starting to see outbreaks in the suburbs and in outlying communities.
Ebola, if you don't know, is incredibly contagious and has a kill rate between 50% and 90%.
It can be transmitted through a drop, a drop of sweat or blood.
So people riding on the subway are sweaty.
You just want to stay away from them anyways, but they're like, "Woohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoohoo
You just want to stay away from them anyways, but they're like, "Woohoohoo, shaking their head like a dog is flying everywhere."
It's like Beethoven, but Ebola infected.
And it can take up to nine days before you start to become symptomatic.
So you can have it and spread it and not know it.
And then you start pooping out blood.
Basically, you liquefy from the inside out.
That's what ends up killing you.
You'll start to get like, some people get rashes, some people get bloodshot eyes.
Some people, it starts off with confusion and things like that.
But the end result that will kill you is massive blood loss.
Your organs liquefy.
And then you throw up and you poop out blood until you die.
It's very brutal.
I've seen some photos of people dying from it.
They're alive.
I saw a photo of a guy sitting in the middle of a street.
He's just blood all on the ground underneath his butt.
He's laying down.
He's sitting.
But you just see a puddle of blood because he's pooping out blood and he's reaching out for help.
And everyone else in the photo has given him like a 10 foot radius.
Because he's dead.
There's nothing you can do.
And part of the problem is not only is Ebola highly contagious,
but the burial rituals in the Congo and in other regions of this area,
they require the people to clean the body, to wash the bodies off.
And if they're a very famous person, sometimes you'll lay on the body.
You'll be like, "Oh, Elvis, such great music.
Let me lay on your body."
Which gives you Ebola.
And then you die and then your loved ones wash your body, clean your body, things like that.
I read an interesting article where the person says,
"Imagine having a millennial old tradition and all of a sudden a couple guys show up
and has mat suits and say, 'Just throw it in a bag and burn it.'"
And that's the problem they're having over in these regions.
They've been having these burial practices for hundreds, hundreds of years.
And now people are showing up in pretty much space suits saying,
"No, can't say goodbye. Just throw it in a bag."
That's it. Can't touch it.
Now it's hitting a city.
Like I said, it's only outskirts. It hasn't gotten to the main part of town.
But it seems like it's only a matter of time.
And here's the problem.
Merrick, the group that makes the Ebola, it's an experimental Ebola vaccine.
So they're not entirely for sure that it works.
They're pretty sure that it works.
They give it to people and it seems to work,
but they've only dealt with basic "minor outbreaks."
The biggest outbreak was around 11,000 people.
So they go, "Okay, well, let's stockpile 300,000 doses of this vaccine."
It takes months to prepare.
But they go 300,000. That's a good starting point.
But with over a million people in the city,
it's not even half that can be vaccinated from this.
You could have a city full of skyscrapers and restaurants and coffee shops and skate parks,
a wash in blood by next summer.
It would be like a zombie movie.
And the weirdest part about this vaccine,
and they don't know what they're going to do,
Merrick has said, you know,
"We don't know if we can have enough vaccines ready to go."
And another thing with this outbreak is people are coming down with Ebola,
and they don't know where they got it from.
Normally, you would have one person go,
"Well, yeah, I was holding hands with that dude."
And that's how I got Ebola.
But now people are showing up and they're like,
"Well, do you know anyone who died of Ebola?"
And they're like, "No, I don't know anyone who died of Ebola."
So it may already get spread in that droplet form.
All it takes to, I mean, this was the big controversy a couple of years ago,
is it takes nine days someone to get on a plane and go to another country,
but they don't have enough vaccines to inoculate an entire city.
They don't know how some people are catching it, which is very worrying.
But the vaccine, I remember reading about this a couple of years ago,
the vaccine itself, so Merrick is a company,
and a company's goal is to make profit.
Companies tend to have secondary goals.
Walmart's goal is to make profit.
And Sam Walton's goal, at least,
you can argue whether or not Walmart's still about it,
but Sam Walton's goal was to give customers low-price items.
That was, I mean, he wanted to make money and keep the company going,
but his secondary goal was to allow people to buy stuff at the lowest price possible.
That's an admirable goal.
Merrick, their main goal is to make money,
and their secondary goal is to help people.
But when you come, and most corporations are like that,
Amazon's like, "Hey, we want you to have access to all the entertainment you want to,
but we also, our main goal is to make money."
There's a little capitalism side note there.
Merrick said, "Listen, we can make this Ebola vaccine,
but the truth of the matter is that Ebola is quite rare.
So the amount of money that we put into making this vaccine, we have to recoup.
Not just the research and development,
but the making, producing the actual physical vaccine itself.
It's quite rare. It'll take us forever to recoup a profit from making this."
And then someone, some genius there,
probably Max Brooks or George Romero, said,
"You know what else is rare?
That we have a vaccine for, that we can stockpile,
but it's so rare it doesn't really make it cost effective for us to make all this vaccine for.
And we can combine them together, and they're like,
"Yes, Mr. Romero, what's your suggestion?"
And he goes, "Rabies.
Rabies is a vaccine that is needed that we have,
but it doesn't make sense for us to make a separate rabies vaccine.
What if we took, this is 100% true.
What if we took the rabies vaccine and the Ebola vaccine,
combined them into a single vaccine,
so we can give it to either person?"
And people are like, "Yay!"
Clapping, having no, then...
You ever wonder why people in zombie movies act like they've never seen a zombie movie?
Because people in our planet act like they've never seen a zombie movie.
Why would you invent something?
Because remember, a vaccine tends to have an element of the disease in the vaccine.
That might not hold true across all vaccines,
but like the flu vaccine, they're like, "Oh yeah, it has a little bit of the flu vaccine.
You might get sick, you might find a little..."
You're gonna give me rabies if I have Ebola?
Or if I have rabies, you're gonna inject me with something that has Ebola in it?
You're basically created a crazy, blood-spuing monster.
Who's just gonna run around, spit in blood at everybody, and doesn't care, because he has rabies.
Why would you combine those two?
Why don't you combine Ebola and like, I don't know, antidepressant medicine,
or something that makes you sleepy?
Anything else!
I guess people who have depression don't want to be injected full of Ebola, but...
Those are the two... those...
That's like at the beginning of "I Am Legend" the movie.
They invent the cure for cancer and it turns everyone into a vampire.
I don't know if I would take that vaccine.
And I don't know if I would hang out with anybody who took that vaccine.
Because again, you've now created a crazy, a 28 days later, rage-infected monster.
No!
Put something else in that vaccine, Merrick.
But 300,000 doses of that rabies/Ebola vaccine is on its way to a major city in Africa.
Okay, the last story we're gonna talk about, it's funny,
because I heard about this story when I was a kid.
Because I've always been reading this weird stuff.
And as I was researching this, I realized the version I heard as a kid was heavily edited.
So we're going to France.
We will take... well, hop in the Carpenter copter,
because I want to get out of the Ebola city of Congo.
We're gonna fly above just right like they're...
They're like running towards the helicopter.
Get on, get on, get on!
Many guns are out of ammo.
Get on!
That's not you making that noise, that's the zombies behind you.
You hop into the helicopter.
It's so funny, I get accused of racism all the time for this podcast.
This isn't helping, but anyways...
They're chasing us down.
Jump in the helicopter.
They're forming like a human pyramid to try to get us...
Take off.
Just as we start to see the nuke coming towards the city.
Anyways, we're gonna go to France.
We're back in time so we don't have to worry about zombies.
I don't know why the helicopter made an airplane noise, but anyways...
Chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-ch
We land.
We're back in time.
Anyways, Tarrere...
That is a skinny man.
He is of normal height.
Whatever that may be.
He's 100 pounds.
He looks to be 100 pounds.
You're like, "Oh man, you didn't eat something."
100 pounds for being in your 20s is quite slender.
That's when he lifts up his shirt and billows of loose skin just...
And like, deflated balloon just kind of like, sloped towards the ground.
And you notice that even though he's only in his 20s, his face is super wrinkly.
He looks like a 100 pound man whose skin is just melted jello.
Now, Tarrere was a medical freak.
There's a few other people who have this condition, but Tarrere is the most notable.
When he was a kid, his appetite was insatiable.
He couldn't stop eating.
And eventually, he literally...
Not literally, but he ate them out of house and home.
He didn't eat the house.
He was like, "You know what, actually he would have."
We'll get to that in a second.
He actually would have given the chance.
And so his parents kicked him out because they were like,
"Oh, we saw you eyeing the floorboards."
They kicked him out because they couldn't afford to keep him.
He ends up joining a bunch of circus freaks and his show was,
"Let me eat whatever you got in your pockets."
"Hey, you. What do you have in your pockets?"
And he's like, "I don't know, a couple shillings."
And he's like, "Well, that's weird. This is France.
You should have francs."
And he's like, "Oh, yes, that's where I meant francs."
So he'd eat the francs.
And he goes, "What do you have?"
And the person's like, "I have this potted plant in my purse."
And he's like, "Give it to me."
"Aah, he'd eat it."
Now, his jaw didn't distend and he ate a whole pot.
But he would eat cats.
He'd be like, "Hey, hey, cat lady. Can I borrow one of those?"
And she's like, "Uh, sure."
And he's gonna pet it and he's like, "Sump."
Pet it from the inside.
He'd rip its stomach open and eat the guts.
And then he would eat everything but the bones.
And then he'd throw up the fur and the skin.
And then at that point, everyone kind of just applauded.
At one point, he was doing this act
and he'd got an obstruction in the stomach
and the other circus performers had to take him to the doctor.
And the doctor was like fixing him up.
And he goes, "Hey, you know, I do this act."
This is your story.
He goes, "You know, I do this act where I can eat anything."
The doctor's like, "Really?"
He's like, "Hey, let me eat your gold watch."
He couldn't stop eating stuff.
And the doctor said, "If you ate my watch,
I'm gonna cut you open and get it out."
To which I imagined Terare, like,
grabbed the collar of his shirt and went, "Gold?"
But anyways, he couldn't stop eating stuff.
Eventually, he joined the military,
which considering that that life is so regimented,
it seemed like a bizarre choice,
but maybe just doing his civic duty.
And he would eat all of his rations
and then he would do chores around the camp
to eat other people's rations.
And then he started eating food out of the garbage.
And that's nothing compared to what's coming.
He started eating food out of the garbage.
And the army was like, "Dude, seriously."
And when he'd eat,
like, all of his loose skin would inflate like a balloon.
He could actually fill his body up with food
and then as it would dissolve,
his skin would get super loose again.
And finally, there was this dude at the camp,
the commander, and he goes,
"This guy's driving me nuts, but I have a plan."
I'm gonna make him swallow little, like,
wooden boxes with battle plans on them.
And then he'll just walk across enemy lines
and no one will notice him,
'cause he just looks like a normal dude.
And then he'll poop out the plans to somebody else.
And so they do a test.
They give him a little wooden box
and put a piece of paper in it,
and he swallows it,
and then a couple days later,
he poops it out, or a couple hours later, whatever,
he poops it out, and the box was fine.
And they're like, "Oh, this plan's gonna work."
Now, let me tell you a little bit more about Tarare.
This was his description.
He had an abnormally wide mouth
and near-invisible lips.
Now, I don't think that meant they were, like,
an invisible woman that you could see through me.
I think they just meant that he had super, super thin lips.
Like I said, his face was super wrinkly,
his skin hung super low.
His skin, like, if you touched him, it was hot.
He was hot to the touch.
He was just probably a big part of his metabolism.
And he was described, this is a quote,
"He stunk to such a degree
that he could not be endured within the distance of 20 paces."
So just a super stink bag.
You didn't want to be near him.
And that was normal.
When he ate, he smelled worse.
He had constant diarrhea, constant diarrhea,
and that gives a new angle to the story of them,
like, waiting around for him to poop out the box,
and then it's all, "Pfft!"
Just like a huge puddle, and they're like,
"Okay, let's get a private in here to dig through this stuff,
'cause I'm not."
He had chronic diarrhea, and it was, and again, quote,
"fetted beyond all conception."
So they should have had a poet in the room,
'cause you hear that phrase,
they should send a poet to space.
They should have had a poet.
Beyond all conception, beyond what great ideas
lay out in the universe they cannot use to describe
the smell of his diarrhea.
And I don't know, I don't know how this is possible,
but they said that you could look at him and vapor,
like, stink lines came out of his skin.
You could see a visible vapor around him.
They're just the stench.
Now let's go back to that plan about using him as a spy.
You want someone to walk across enemy lines.
France was at war with pressure at this point.
You pick a guy who has big, big, flabby cheeks,
stinks from 20 meters away,
has visible vapor lines coming off of him,
and constantly has to stop to have diarrhea.
Needless to say, the plan didn't really work.
He eventually, when he went back, he's like,
he didn't want to do any more army stuff,
so he volunteered to go to hospital.
The doctors were like, "Oh my God, this is amazing.
We can't wait to see how this dude works."
They tried curing him.
One of the cures was soft-boiled eggs.
Let's give him as many soft-boiled eggs as we can.
He's like, "Go, go, go, go, go."
Didn't work out too well.
One of the things was they had a meal spread,
a table spread for 15 laborers
who were working at the hospital at that time,
so they had all this food laid out,
and they go, "Hmm, the doctors are like,
"I wonder what will happen if we give him food
"that is set aside for 15 able-bodied men."
He ate it all. He ate it all.
He complained about hunger all the time.
If he wasn't eating, he was constantly exhausted,
so it wasn't just like this circus freak,
"Let me swallow anything."
He was constantly hungry.
He had to eat. That's why he was digging through the garbage.
So they saw him eat all that food, and they're like,
"Okay, okay, enough fun, guys.
"Let's go back to trying to cure him."
And they would put him on these regulated diets.
But the problem is, is that he wouldn't stick to him.
He would break out of the hospital
or just walk out of the hospital at night.
And there was a butcher shop that, you know,
they throw all their scraps in the dump
and the garbage behind the butcher shop.
I imagine it's like the lady in the tramp.
There's just a bunch of spaghetti back there.
He would go through that, but so would stray dogs.
So he had to fight stray dogs for food every night
just to get some extra food.
In this hospital, because we're in the 1700s,
bloodletting was a thing. They had a bloodletting ward.
"Hmm, you're sick.
"Let's take as much blood out of you as possible.
"That might cure you."
He would drink their blood.
He would go in there and he'd be like,
"Gulp, gulp, gulp."
And you can imagine like a nurse was walking through the hospital
and saw like a silhouette crouched over with like a hose in his mouth.
And she's like, "Tar rare. What are you doing out of your room?"
And he's like, "Gulp."
And then they caught him.
No joke, 'cause imagine having a hunger
that's on the level of a heroin addiction.
Like you have to eat. You have to eat.
They caught him in the morgue trying to eat corpses.
And they're like, "Tar rare."
No, at that point they were really concerned about...
So the end of his hospital stay,
the end of all the experiments ends like this.
Tarare's in the hospital.
And he's probably sitting there and he has like
an odd shaped lump in his stomach.
I don't know if that's true. I don't know if that's true, but...
Okay, let me try to stick to the fact.
[laughs]
The fact... Okay.
The fact of the story is...
[laughs]
The fact of the story is,
Tarare is in the hospital.
And it was a fully functional hospital.
So they had like the bloodletting ward and the morgue
and other stuff going on there,
including a maternity ward.
Oh wait, this baby wouldn't be there,
'cause this baby was 14 months old,
but they did have a maternity ward.
So, not the maternity ward, 'cause this baby's too old.
This baby's graduated.
The baby's there for some checkup.
French measles.
They wanna make sure the baby doesn't have French measles.
So...
But one day the mom's like, "Here baby, 14 month old baby,
I'm gonna set you down on this chair while I read
this old timey wood carving magazine."
She's like, getting splinters, reading this wood carving magazine.
And she turns back,
"Baby's gone. Baby's gone."
Now, I don't know if that exact sequence of events happened either.
The point is, is that Tarare was in a hospital
and a 14 month old baby went completely missing.
They never, ever found the kid.
And the fur-- they didn't go, "Oh, Tarare!"
This time, they were like, "That dude ate a baby.
That guy straight up ate a baby."
And he took off. He ran out.
That's the end of that story.
I was like, "There has to be another answer.
There has to be that they found the baby later."
But from all accounts, he ate a living baby,
which isn't far from the other stuff he's done.
We know he's eaten live cats and live dogs,
and he's tried eating humans, so, I mean,
babies kind of look like food.
They look like little rolls.
Now, I would never eat a baby, but they look puffy.
And so, Tarare, as hungry as he is,
he could just be like, "Ah, it'll probably taste like
dinner rolls and marshmallows."
I don't know. That's super disgusting.
But anyways, actually, you think they would have found the bones,
because he doesn't eat that.
He runs out of the hospital.
Eventually, though, at age 26,
died very, very young.
He goes and he says--
he goes to the Southern doctor, and he's like,
"Oh, hi, I'm Tarare. You might know me from the baby eating scandal."
But I ate a gold fork a while ago,
and I think it's still in me, and I'm super sick.
Now, the doctor's looking at this saggy,
fetid, gross diarrhea monster,
and he's thinking, you know, a guy who ate a gold fork--
that's not the weirdest thing about you,
but let's take a look.
So, he starts treating him, and he goes,
"No, you don't have-- you may or may not have eaten a golden fork,
but you have tuberculosis."
Advanced tuberculosis.
And Tarare's like, "No, trust me, dude, I ate a gold fork.
It's in my stomach. It really hurts.
I've eaten tons of stuff, but for some reason,
that's not sitting well with me."
The fact that it's a four-pronged metal object,
he eventually does die, though.
And in his last moments, like the last couple hours of his life,
ten times the worst diarrhea.
He was pooping out pus,
pus and blood-filled diarrhea,
and then he dies.
A fitting way to end to a man who had diarrhea his entire life.
He had to tie-- he had to one-up it.
And so, one of the doctors who treated him
at the baby-eating hospital came to this hospital,
because they called him up, and they're like,
"Hey, remember that baby-eating scandal?"
And he's like, "Oh, yeah. We have that guy here."
He says he ate a gold fork.
And you can imagine the doctor at the other hospital.
By that time, the phone's already, like,
hanging off the desk, and he's in his jalopy
to get to this hospital, or a horse,
because they didn't have cars back then,
to get there, because he's like, "Dude, I need to find--
I want to find this guy, because this guy was like a medical marvel."
And he gets there, and the body's just laying there,
and it's super stinky, and none of the doctors want to do an autopsy,
and the baby-eating hospital doctor says,
"I'll do it. I need to find out what made this guy tick."
So they cut him open.
His throat cavity was so huge that if you opened his mouth,
you could look down into his stomach.
His body cavity was filled with pus.
Like, his liver was covered in pus,
and it was just like an ocean of mucus in there.
And his stomach, all over the inside of his stomach, were ma--
and his stomach was huge, by the way, like his actual stomach cavity,
but all over the inside of his stomach were these massive, gross, disgusting tumors.
I don't-- it wasn't in the description.
They were gross and disgusting, but I'm sure they were.
I don't think that's a stretch of the imagination.
And no golden fork.
So the question is, did he really eat the golden fork?
Probably, for whatever reason, 'cause he's terraria.
But did he poop it out at some point,
or was his stomach acid so intense he can actually melt metal, or gold?
I guess gold is a metal, but...
That's the story of terraria.
Now, like I said, when I read the story when I was a kid,
it was like, there's this goofy guy named Terraria.
He'd eat anything.
He was a circus performer, and he ate corks and screws,
and once he even ate a cat.
And then he turned the page, and it's like about the two-headed wolf girl or something like that.
Nothing about eating babies.
Nothing about puss and philda diarrhea.
None of that stuff.
But I remembered that story as a kid,
looking through, like, Ripley's Believe It or Not, or some crazy person, like,
crazy people in history book.
They took out all the good stuff.
That's why I found it for you guys on Dead Rabbit Radio.
There we go.
I liked that take.
Took me four tries.
But we got it.
It takes a while to warm up on Mondays.
It's weird, because I have those two days where I don't do anything,
but I went and took a shower, and I was like, I gotta do it.
It's my job.
I gotta do it.
But we had a good one.
I really liked this episode.
Now.
Now I like this episode.
DeadRabbitRadio@gmail.com is going to be your email address.
You can also hit us up at facebook.com/DeadRabbitRadio.
Twitter is @JasonOCarpenter.
Dead Rabbit Radio is the daily paranormal conspiracy and true crime podcast.
We don't have to listen to it every day, but I'm glad you listened to it today.
Have a great one, guys.
(upbeat music)